PICK UP WITH THE WARMER WEATHER.
BILL MELUGIN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ARKANSAS REPUBLICAN SENATOR TOM
COTTON JOINS ME NOW.
SENATOR, FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
GET YOUR TOP LINE REACTION TO
THESE NUMBERS WE'RE HEARING.
>> THESE ARE ASTONISHING SURGES
IN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION THAT THE
OUR BORDER.
AS WE HEARD TR BILL THERE WAS A
RECORD IN 2021, THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ENCOUNTERED AT THE BORDER IN 22
YEARS.
JUST THE ONES THEY ENCOUNTERED
NOT THE ONES THAT GOT AWAY.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT RESTING ON HIS
LAURELS AFTER SETTING THE
RECORD LAST YEAR.
HE WANTS TO BREAK HIS OWN
RECORD.
WE MIGHT HAVE MORE THAN TWO
MILLION ILLEGALS CROSSING OUR
BORDER THIS YEAR.
THOSE ARE NOT PEOPLE SEEKING
ASYLUM FROM PERSECUTION.
THEY'RE COMING FOR ONE REASON
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT JOE
BIDEN WILL LET THEM IN.
IT IS DANGEROUS FOR AMERICA.
MANY TIMES THEY ARE SMUGGLING
IN DRUGS AS WELL.
GANG MEMBERS OR OTHER CRIMINALS
CROSSING OUR UNCONTROLLED
BORDER.
>> Harris: THEY KNOW THEY CAN
MIX IN WITH THE PACK AND WE
CAN'T CATCH THEM ALL AND
WITHOUT TITLE 42 I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH COVID TESTING WE'RE
DOING ANYWAY.
BUT WE ARE AT A REAL, REAL
STANDPOINT NOW IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO SLOW THAT DISEASE
DOWN.
THAT VIRUS DOWN IF THIS
ONSLAUGHT IS COMING.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
ONLY AN AUDIO LOG LIKE JOE
BIDEN AND DEMOCRATIC PARTY CAN
THINK THERE IS NO PANDEMIC AT
THE BORDER AND NO CASES BUT
INSIST THAT AMERICAN TODDLERS
WEAR MASKS WHEN THEY TRAVEL ON
AIRPLANES AND TRAINS.
>> Harris: THERE IS SO MUCH
HYPOCRISY IN ALL OF THIS.
IT IS WHAT THEY WANT
POLITICALLY.
SPEAKING OF COVID.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WARNING
PEOPLE SHOULD BE PREPARED FOR
RENEWED COVID RESTRICTIONS AS
WE SEE A NEW VARIANT EMERGE AND
CASES ON THE RISE AGAIN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I DON'T WANT TO USE THE WORD
LOCKDOWN, IT HAS A CHARGED
ELEMENT TO IT.
WE MUST KEEP OUR EYE ON THE
PATTERN OF WHAT WE SEE WITH
INFECTIONS.
WE SHOULD BE PREPARED AND
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO PIFSHIOT
TOWARDS GOING BACK AT LEAST
TEMPORARILY TO A MORE RIGID
TYPE OF RESTRICTION SUCH AS
REQUIRING MASKS INDOORS.
>> Harris: WE SHOULD BE
PREPARED AND NIMBLE ENOUGH TO
GET TO THE BORDER AND TALK
ABOUT THOSE THINGS.
A NEW NATIONAL POLL FINDS A
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
SUPPORT A RETURN TO MASKING AND
SOCIAL DISTANCING GUIDANCE, A
WHOPPING 62% SAY THEY OPPOSE IT.
BUT THE PARTY BREAKDOWN SHOWS A
DIFFERENT STORY.
62% OF DEMOCRATS SUPPORT
BRINGING BACK THOSE
RESTRICTIONS.
VERY FEW REPUBLICANS WANT TO
SEE THAT.
MEANWHILE 21 STATES ARE SUING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVER
MASK MANDATES ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
SENATOR TOMMY SOOUBERVILLE WITH
THIS.
>> THE MASKS PEOPLE ARE WEARING
IN SCHOOLS AND PLANES DON'T
WORK AND DON'T HELP.
IT IS CONTROL.
YOU KNOW THAT, IT IS CONTROL BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL EVERYTHING
YOU DO.
>> Harris: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE RIGHT NOW?
A MAJORITY OF THEM ARE STILL
JUST OUT OF OBLIGATION WEARING
THEIR MASK HALF DOWN THEIR
NOSE, CLOTH MASK.
HE HAS A GOOD POINT.
WHAT THEY ARE CHOOSING TO DO
WOULDN'T HELP ANYWAY.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SENSIBLE ABOUT THESE THINGS.
THEY RECOGNIZE THE CORONAVIRUS
WILL BE ENDEMIC AND ALWAYS
PRESENT AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IT IN THE SAME WAY WE DEAL WITH
THE COLD, FLU AND OTHER
DISEASES.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO UPEND OUR
LIFE AS FAUCI SAYS BE PREPARED
FOR THE NEXT SURGE THAT HE WILL
TELL US WE HAVE TO WEAR MASKS
AND STAY OUT OF PUBLIC PLACES
AND SHUT DOWN OUR BUSINESSES.
TONY FAUCI SHOULD BE PREPARED
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT WHY HE
LIED TO CONGRESS AND GOOD HOW
HIS AGENCY FUNDED THE LABS IN
WUHAN WHEN REPUBLICANS TAKE
BACK CONGRESS THIS FALL.
THAT'S WHERE HE WILL BE IN
JANUARY.
>> Harris: BANK RECORDS SHOW
HUNTER BIDEN RECEIVED $100,000
FROM A CHINESE ENERGY FIRM NOT
THAT LONG AGO, IN 2017.
REPUBLICAN SENATORS RON
JOHNSON, CHUCK GRASSLEY
REVEALING THE FINANCIAL
DOCUMENTS ON THE SENATE FLOOR
THIS WEEK.
>> THERE IS NO MIDDLEMAN IN
THIS TRANSACTION.
THIS IS $100,000 FROM WHAT IS
EFFECTIVELY AN ARM OF THE
COMMUNIST CHINESE GOVERNMENT
DIRECT TO HUNTER BIDEN.
TO THE LIBERAL MEDIA AND MY
DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES, IS THIS
OFFICIAL BANK DOCUMENT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION?
>> Harris: FLORIDA CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ.
AN INVESTIGATION IF REPUBLICANS
MAKE THE MAJORITY.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO SENATOR
COTTON.
>> SPEAKING OF PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD HAVE PREPARED TO TESTIFY
TO CONGRESS IN JANUARY WHEN
REPUBLICANS ARE IN CHARGE.
HUNTER BIDEN AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST AND JAMES BIDEN AND DEVIN
ARCHER THEIR BUSINESS PARTNER.
THE MEDIA AND BIG TECH SUP
PRESSED THE STORY IN 2020
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WOULD
HURT BIDEN'S ELECTORAL CHANCES.
OTHER EXECUTIVES MIGHT WANT TO
TESTIFY ABOUT WHAT THEY DID TO
CALL THIS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION WHEN IN REALITY
IT WAS ALWAYS CLEAR THAT IT WAS
TRUE FROM THE BEGINNING.
HUNTER BIDEN HAS BEEN
FEATHERING THE BIDEN FAMILY
NEST FOR DECADES OFF HIS
FATHER'S PUBLIC SERVICE AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE ANSWERS
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND
FOR ALL WE KNOW WHAT COULD BE
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: SENATOR QUICKLY
BEFORE I LET YOU GO.
I'VE MADE THE POINT MANY TIMES
THE REASON WHY WE CARE ABOUT
THIS STORY IS NONPARTISAN AND
AS A JOURNALIST YOU ALWAYS WANT
TO BE ABLE TO SAY YOU FOUND
EVERY WAY POSSIBLE TO SEE THE
FACTS AROUND VULNERABILITY WITH
A MAN WHO LEADS THE NATION AND
ARGUABLY THE FREE WORLD.
THIS IS A CONDUIT OF
VULNERABILITY IF HUNTER BIDEN
IS DOING WHAT?
>> IF HE IS ACCEPTING SIX AND
SEVEN AND EIGHT FIGURE PAYOFFS
FROM FOREIGN OLIGARCHS AND
GOVERNMENTS, AS HE HAS FOR
YEARS, HARRIS, FOR ALMOST AS
LONG AS HUNTER BIDEN HAS BEEN A
GROWN ADULT HE HAS BEEN TRADING
OFF HIS FATHER'S PUBLIC SERVICE.
FIRST IN THE SENATE, THEN AS
VICE PRESIDENT.
DO WE REALLY THINK THAT BIRD IS
GOING TO CHANGE HIS FEATHERS
WHEN HIS FATHER GETS THE
BIGGEST JOB OF ALL?
YOU COULD SAY THE SAME THING
FOR JOE BIDEN'S BROTHER AS WELL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
ANSWERS TO THIS.